yeah that was me saying ken
ken oh
hang on it just went
and then cut out it today we're checking
out oh my god
sorry a little delayed i mean all the
way in australia sorry
god damnit get your [ __ ] together kid
okay my bad my bad sorry
today we're checking out life of luxury
have you ever seen this game never oh
great
cool it wasn't like you recommended it
to check this out either
which which one are we going to watch
these all right there's so many good
options we have
screaming dog sleeping
dad sleeping crawling oh my god
sleeping red arrows oh my goodness i've
been doing my thumbnails wrong this is
great
we're gonna check out her son can't stop
growing at night
oh my god that is when you grow the most
as a child
yeah during your sleep sounds regenerate
we used to my kids that so they'd like
actually take naps like oh you know
you're not gonna grow big and tall
unless you
take a nap oh my god i fell for a lie
and i thought it was real
damn it you're telling me that
that's just what parents tell their kids
oh well
you're telling me it's true i just told
them that well because that's what my
parents told me
[Music]
damn it well i mean apparently your
parents fed you dog food too or
something i don't know what's wrong with
you
and your understanding of kids but
anyway it's a whole other conversation
let's watch this video what is it about
what's happening the sun's growing okay
okay she's having problems with her son
they should be going to therapy
i don't think therapy is going to help
with that
dude sit down we gotta have a talk dude
you're growing too much you're too tall
that's what they do wrong in horror
movies every time there's some
dude we got to talk about this you're
being a total jerk in this house
possessing people killing people not
murdered your whole family stop it
[Music]
[Applause]
some porn level acting here this is
really nice
yeah man this is the best there there's
already a hole in the wall
like this is hitting the same place
so this is real right oh yes yes
what see well hang on disclaimer these
videos produce the intention of
entertaining for artistic purposes the
ecstasy should not be replicated
so yeah definitely 100 real damn it i
was about to replicate all of it
at this point goddammit let's hit
100 000 likes for more videos oh this
guy does not know how to do youtube what
the
hello look you got it what's up
bloodthorn me
hey
[Music]
dude they got almost freaking seven they
got almost 800 000 likes on this
jesus i mean it works [ __ ] all right i
have to give all the nudes out all right
maybe they know what's going on my bad
damn got more subs than me okay let me
try
what's up bro army if you like this
video
and we got a hundred thousand i will
make another video tomorrow
which i would have done anyway but i
need
valentine's day what happens if you
don't get the likes you just like well
that's it
i guess the channel is over with
well there's been i remember there's
been cases of youtubers like actually
holding videos hostage but like well
i said it and you guys didn't do this
the light goal so
[ __ ] you jesus can't do it you can't do
anything right
can you luxury army huh idiots
email from a woman named candace a 53
year old mother
who believes there's something horribly
wrong with her son
candy says her doesn't talk to her
anymore and it seems like he cannot stop
growing to the point where he can barely
fit in his clothes
so what's the reason that she calls
these guys are they
because they are youtubers who appeal
to a younger audience so they know a
thing or two about a kid that's going
through puberty
like this man actually is he can't stop
growing he doesn't he's all moody
doesn't talk to his mom he doesn't fit
into his clothes
she doesn't know what to do too many
times we'll we'll do that you can't
you can't just keep napping all right
she says he's been pulling out his hair
and won't let her
see his face she sent us this video for
proof
tommy oh she feeds some dog food the
story continues
the dog this is what happens
it says poops you know or solid or
whatever it is i guess i'm
i'm willing to admit i was wrong ken you
shouldn't feed your kids dog food
oh well thank thank you finally for
admitting that that is dog food right
that is not actual
yeah you do that or tuna fish i'm not
too sure i think it maybe
yeah here you go son here i got your
meal ready for you
oh yeah delicious dinner
do you want it sweetie
so tonight oh god
no no mom i don't want the down downfall
i don't want you can you be so rude if i
have kids they're eating the dog food
okay there's nothing they talk to me
like that
where are they we're gonna have a talk
there will be no more nap time
just dog food head out to her house and
see what's happening with her son
when she's not watching him oh
he just sits and play fortnite all day
so what do you think is going on with
this lady's son i really don't
understand the problem
sunglasses at night that's what i'm
talking about i
love the acting it's so good heck yeah
dude it's like top tiers it's great
hey ken what are you so what do you like
think of this video so far ken dude it's
like
like the best dude like they're gonna
get like so many likes
like it's gonna be crazy dude like wow
and i sh i sure hope they figure out
what's wrong with their son
yeah dude i hope this is the end with
like dude like
nothing being resolved at all dude
that'd be crazy
oh yeah gotta have the ray-bans at night
gotta have it so what do you think's
going on with this he's the man all
right
hello okay dude i i was called out once
for having sunglasses a neck
and it wasn't my fault this random guy
just came up and was like why are you
wearing sunglasses at night
i'm like i actually don't know
what how is that not your fault because
i came from a flight
okay it was bright when i left the
flight that came out
no longer bright and i was so used to
having them
right okay got you so he's had him on
the plane okay yeah
you don't have to do me like that man
why would you
not even have to say that i got the
transition lenses on my glasses
and uh oh i was one of those yeah
they're
they're great they're fantastic i don't
have to like swap out like prescription
sunglasses but
i was told that that's what old people
get for their glasses
other people are doing it right okay oh
cool people get those for the guys
i also got like the new balance like dad
shoes like the dad shoes
they are so uncomfortable which ones are
the dad shoes the nikes
the white knight oh they're the white
new balance ones like
just google it you'll see them you'll
you'll know yeah that's literally them
that yeah
yes how did i know that oh
it's the ones at the top left right
there yeah that's the ones
yeah that's how you know you're in here
oh they're not in here but they're
freaking comfy boy
oh you old people got it going on
they figured it out yeah you get old
you're like screw looking good i just
want to be
comfortable and that's it they look
amazing they're top fashion [ __ ]
they're they're great they're great so
are my transition lenses okay
yeah and i used to have a wallet phone
case i have a different phone case now
but you know it used to be
it used to be wallet like the wallet
have my cards and everything in it
that's another
that's another dad thing isn't it yeah
i'm just 100 dad and
you know i'm not mad about i even got my
dad's shirt on right now it's
like a it's like a fishing shirt it's
got like are you
you know the sweat wicking technology
you know it's a fishing shirt that's
weird sweat technology all right you
know i'm pretty cool bro what other
what other dad tricks do you have up
your sleeve i
hey what's what's brown what's brown and
sticky
i don't know a stick
does that work on your kids yeah yeah
where the cows go on the weekends
to the movies
what's what's a cat's favorite color
purple
what do you call a deer with no eyes i
have no idea
okay all right what are what have you
done to ken no you need to sense now
stop it
you're gonna be in life a luxury video
this continues
her son's been growing super fast for
some reason and
acting really creepy towards her dude
that doesn't make any sense
or something dude that doesn't make any
sense i'm so puzzled by this
how does that happen what oh yeah
dude he's talking over here
dude if this woman's having problems
with her son they should be going to
therapy
okay okay fine
okay whatever have fun
but like it still makes no sense
[Music]
the drive nice
it looks spooky i got some fog right
here this is it bro
okay something seems really wrong here
dude the windows are all dark
dude i don't know if i want to meet
these people this could just be like a
waste of time
well at the very least let's just go in
and meet candace no those windows are
dark
okay okay
there's so much to comment about but
this video is 20 minutes uh yeah
there's just there's so much like it's
already like freaking 12 minutes in sobs
over there like looking like bruh
come on they're using the dslr cameras
to vlog i love it
yeah yeah
you can use the doorbell as well it's
right next to the door but okay
they're asleep okay don't wake up
everybody
hi candace right
yeah can these nuts spitting all right
good one thank you
we told you we were coming tonight okay
uh we can come in right
okay why is the mom weird that's the the
whole point is that she asks for help
she seems very confused about them being
there
oh they got the mirror turned around
backwards so the camera light doesn't
reflect off of it nice nice good thing
yeah well done
well done oh let's just sit down and
talk with you okay
weird house is this there's like two
doors okay yeah
and then i mean they picked a good place
okay let's just sit down and talk with
you and there's a tiny door there that's
so cute
like the alice in wonderland house yeah
the three bears
mama bear papa bear anyway my porridge
okay candace thank you for uh letting us
practical of the walls uh can you give
us more details
she's renovating son right right son
it's my fault i fed them dog food
i shouldn't have done that so you told
us in the email you sent us that you
know he's been acting
really strange can you go into that more
he's
he's still my boy he just doesn't talk
to me anymore
i mean i can see her very concerned
about him which is you know a good thing
but
when did all this start happening with
him
after michael passed michael was your
husband
damn he ran into the woods he was gone
for about three days
i almost called the police i almost why
he was gone in the woods for three days
you can call it cops
he'll be back i thought about it at
least that's what can't
okay yeah yeah yeah oh great
he came back into his room through his
window
the window why are you coming through
the front door yeah
i don't know he just completely shut
down and now he wears this change mask
it's just like he's not my tummy
yes well you mentioned that his father
passed away
are you sure this isn't like some type
of grieving no
this isn't grieving uh-huh
hospital or something that sounds
horrible i'm sure she's
thought about it ken okay yeah
no you call the youtubers gotta vlog it
it's funny because
i feel like these videos could work if
we i mean they're trying i'm not hating
on them or anything but
it's just so fast it's like it's like
the premise of everything
yeah yeah just like think about it okay
yeah it's like a creepypasta and they're
trying to recreate it and vlog it i i i
appreciate it i mean they're doing great
[ __ ] 28
25 million views but the acting is so
good
i love it i think he's self-conscious of
it
well self-conscious bones don't fit into
his skin anymore you know
don't comment about his abnormally long
arms
why would they arrive at 11 34 why would
they
come at a normal time well they see
these are these are youtubers they don't
actually wake up until like yeah
that's right yeah that's when we all
film our videos
except you and me for whatever reason
again jesus christ four boomers you know
yeah tommy
i'm gonna open the door i don't ruin
this kill streak
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait where's the lock on the outside the
door is trying to keep him in there
i guess so like the latch lock you can't
you can't undo that from the inside
what kind of serial killer okay they got
plastic on the wall
the mother turned around maybe the mom
that's the oh my god
it's the evil one after all tommy
my name is parker i'm friends with your
mom
um she invited me here to talk to you to
make sure you're okay
nice
are you feeling alright your mom's uh
been worried about the way you've been
acting
tommy is that a you could turn around so
we could
talk face to face
i push my fingers i do whoa
that's actually creepy
nice nice love that
man how do they do that i mean wow
okay tommy uh if you want to talk more
chester and i
will be here all night bro get out of
the house what you mean be here all
night
he's getting hooked lock him in
chester's trying to score with your mom
dude
chester's like dude i got these
sunglasses on you know she's got a
husband apparently he's missing so yeah
yeah yeah she she's been lonely
i gotta talk to you
i'm in love with the mom bro that was
that was the leap singer slipping down
here this is
someone famous person's house did you
see his face
what was that
yeah it could be some sort of grieving
thing after his dad passed
how could that be a grieving thing dude
i don't know i mean
we came here to set up cameras so why
don't you start setting them up
dude i'm afraid to see what this guy
even does at night but let's just say
the cameras
bro it is night what are you talking
about the freaking chester
i like i like the character like the
play they play it off like chester's
like dude
this doesn't make any sense this is dumb
we should get out of here and the other
guy's like
no she's going through some hard times
you know we shouldn't you know judge a
book by his
head spinning around backwards i'm sure
we just uh that's up dude it happens
yeah
yeah yeah that's fine get the gopros
took five minutes they got the extra
battery packs on them so they last an
hour
let's go
i'm going to the bathroom oh dude
at least he makes us better get in here
yeah that's nice
okay what's this the dog food there's
like some sort of like
meat or something here
the real monster he moves that happens
to teenage boys that's
normal that's perfectly normal
oh my god stop
oh he's going to play it off now let's
just go i set the camera
but the meat moved bro i swear
that was gross just completely
camera in the mom's room hell yeah hey
yo girl what up we get a feeling
for the camera here
that's so weird why would they do that
she's looking
sure go ahead
me sleep boys okay candace so we set up
cameras all over your house
and we put one in tommy's room too
what is this finger movement hey yeah we
said that
yeah hey he's
[Applause]
um well he doesn't know that we put one
in there and he's a little little sweaty
on the pits there you know i'm gonna
oh i didn't notice that oh damn bro
[Music]
let's go okay candace chest and i are
gonna do our best
but uh we need to see how your son acts
at night first
canvas listen yeah that's important yeah
we need to go down
let's go see how he acts at night that's
how you get to know somebody
okay he just sleeps normally
there's nothing here so there's nothing
we can do we're out of here pack it up
then why did they need a camera in her
room i know
why not you know what i'm saying all
right all right
creep a little bit you know all right
bro when we were talking to tommy i got
a really bad feeling did you see the way
that he looked this
guy is so good i love it it's
weird it's crazy are they gonna sleep
together is that what's happening here
yeah
dude together that's what i'm talking
about let's film it just so people know
that we didn't do anything weird or
anything oh
that's what it is this is like they're
they're a couple and this is like their
kink you know let's let's go over to
people's haunted houses and like you
know
set some cameras right they'll lay in
the bed and i'm saying maybe something
creepy will happen whoo-hoo
is exciting yeah
i know it was creepy but we really don't
know what he might be going through
i just feel like he doesn't want us in
this house bro i don't feel safe
sleeping here
yeah and neither does candace and that's
her own son
that's why we're here i want these guys
to make a movie that would be so good
please i would love it i love the logic
i don't feel safe here yeah neither does
his mom that's why they sleep together
they don't feel safe by the way yeah
okay i got a cuddle
[Music]
they're spooning we go to sleep
i swear nothing else
these things on his back that's the
weirdest part of this video what a
psychopath
how do you sleep on this side or my
belly
belly you say you're sleeping what the
hell is wrong with you
i mean yeah i sleep on my back because
that it's like a you know
it's like a persona thing you're like a
strong manly man you sleep on your back
you know scared little soybeans you lay
on your belly
don't hurt me oh no get out of here get
out of
here yeah you google it google it
what does how you sleep say about you
yeah uh backs oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah back sleepers
oh you got pain you got so much pain ken
did something happening
no no it wasn't let's say this ain't the
right one look
we can find another one find something
that supports what i'm saying
solar star starfish side sleeper let's
go
good digestion [ __ ] help us reduce
snoring
you've been scared are you snoring
you've been snoring even by brain health
side sleeping may help back pain as well
so sleeping may help
great oh yeah yeah yeah right right
there's gotta be there's gotta be a
better one
nine positions from their meanings the
yearner the log
guess the log you lie on your side with
both arms straight down
it's only six percent six percent sleep
like that
six percent what blinking in
how do you sleep like that that is so
weird
this is a terrible sight i don't
understand what these are like why they
got these names like just tell me what
i sleep in my back i guess i'm a free
faller
yeah seems to be more common with gen
xers and millennials according to recent
research what
some say free fallers don't take
criticism that is bulky
you don't know me you don't know
anything about me
idiots outspoken yeah i told you what it
means okay me you soy boy sleep on your
belly i can't sleep in my belly
it makes my it actually makes my back
hurt sleeping on my belly looks like i
got a big belly i guess
yeah you don't have the balls to balance
it out that's what's happening
my belly like sinks into the bed because
it's so heavy and like art
oh my back but they're
you know the balls sometimes balance it
out what do you mean
what what so now you catch caught it
sometimes marxian sleeps on her back
and she keeps her legs up
like the cartoon like dead position like
straight up in the air
i'm scared ken i'm scared no wait what
like her knees are up in the air she
how do you sleep like that i don't no
way i don't know
like she just tucks her knees up
i'm scared yeah i'm scared too
like it looked like a childish standing
on top of her under the bed
so we're gonna have to call up life of
luxury and get them to put some cameras
i need help chilling
[Music]
definitely definitely just going through
puberty
normal
nobody knows nobody suspects were they
off on the shelf right now we're seeing
it oh man oh
oh that's what's happening okay guys
he's growing he just grew a lot
nice i'll be a strong boy you're very
strong
very strong oh
got his new legs and arms out hit that
twerk he got he's thirsty he's gonna
go for a little snack maybe
oh man oh no he's seen the gopro
oh my god
so they said that he went to the
bathroom earlier do you think they had
like an awkward
like in the hallway like oh you're going
to the bat oh oh sorry
how does this dude go the bathroom you
know you got that you hover over it
right you just kind of hover and plop it
in
yeah hell yeah
this is literally everyone going for a
midnight snack i don't see the big deal
there's nothing wrong here yeah oh oh
oh oh it goes so it was good that they
had a camera there
oh this is okay i don't understand the
layout of this house
you can go back to where you when you
like open the door like when he when he
opens it like see there's there's room
behind him he opens there's nothing
maybe it's just the lighting maybe maybe
there is something back there
uh sleep they suspect nothing
is he trying to close the door
how can you sleep through this oh
okay oh oh yeah so that's how he grows
nice is she dead oh my god she's dead
she's chilling either very surprised
oh yeah the camera oh he knows
oh my gosh 7 a.m what's gonna happen but
now i can't
wait am right now we just woke up dude
did you hear anything last night
yeah with this dude i don't know maybe i
had a weird dream
okay well can you go wake up candace
i'll go set up the footage so we can
watch it
all right i'll go home it's in the
it's the morning you just turn on the
light and you don't need to have that
all right you know it doesn't matter
yeah it stays but it stays dark the
whole time because
yeah okay yeah all the lights start
right no
no it is oh hello
ooh
but i mean she hit her she hit her neck
but okay
no it's just this is why you sleep on
your back so no one your child isn't
noticed
this morning inject pig
parker parker dude
i'm gonna hold the camera help her oh
they got my camera this is a good one i
can tell
nice dude where did they find this woman
as well
what kind of acting gig is these do you
think they're in la
uh probably
i like how they all have the same bed
frame too they kind of just like rented
a couple of
a couple of things to be able to make it
there's nothing else there's nothing
else in this house there's a black mark
on her back
are you okay bruh bruh
it's a black bar got a bag it's
and it's totally seven a.m right now i
can't believe it
they have a wheelchair he just has a
wheelchair in their head
he just like ran into the wall too
[Laughter]
man got my wheelchair i found it
okay so let's look at this footage from
last night
okay so it looks like tommy wasn't
sleeping much at all
he's very active at night i can see that
oh my god he's going into my
is nobody freaked out weirdy lungs oh my
god
what's he doing oh my god
what is he doing that's so weird does he
do that that's super weird
that's weird right kids don't do that
like a mosquito is that why you can't
walk that's your spine
oh man i love it this is so good
this is so good oh
beautiful that's your spine is that why
you won't walk
you gotta put in a wheelchair it's so
annoying
look what he did to you this isn't oh my
god i have to call the police
no no no why not
they won't understand tommy okay well if
you don't want to call the police
chester and i need to go talk to him
right now no
that's the next step yeah all right no
don't do that
don't do that then why did you call them
we don't call the police we need to go
have a
word yeah we're gonna have a sid man
this tongue business spine thing
knock it off man stop it he's like all
right sorry guys
my bad bro what the hell did we just
watch why doesn't she want to call the
police
dude i don't know that was horrible
i don't know that i never seen acting
this good and i'm
it's so good it's s plus quality right
here
this is the best it looked like he was
sucking her spinal fluid out like a
mosquito or something
did you see the way he was walking i
think he grew more last night
we gotta get out of here well now it's
more clear than ever that this lady
needs our help
definitely stay here one more time come
on
one more night we don't have a choice
yes let's do
it the ladies hit her it just had her
spinal fluid sucked out
they call the hospital you know yeah
i really just don't want him in here
again tonight
i mean i don't know what to do here i
don't i there's nothing we can do to
stop that there's no
lock made on the door already so i i
don't know how possible
we definitely can't lock him into his
room that's for sure yeah that's
unfortunate
are you sure we can't just call the
they police understand them and then
talk to them at least i want to see this
conversation well listen
how about we put this chair here against
your door handle
in case he tries to get in again
there's no way he's going to be able to
get through this and now we're locked in
as well
how do you get out now okay so we're all
set now
if he tries to come in again chester and
i are going to be right in the other
room
try to get some sleep okay we'll watch
your footage in the morning okay
one would be okay wait what do they did
all day
just hanging out with the mom no a whole
day passed for sure
okay try to get some sleep all right
we'll talk in the morning
bro you can't tell me i love that's his
thing every time
okay cameron go bro this is crazy what
is
bro happening i don't feel safe bro get
me out of here please bro
you still stay sleeping if we made
videos like this who would you be would
you be
would you be gesturing chester for sure
yeah
so i gotta be the guy going like dude we
gotta stay here yeah
we gotta we gotta get to the bottom i
wanna
i wanna do it she's so fun i love that
yes i can just imagine you do it you'd
be like what do you mean
getting mad and yelling
this is so good what are the other
options
we can leave dude let's just repeat
tonight
if that's fair it's definitely 200 man
all right but the second i hear anything
i'm leaving
okay whatever let's just go to bed he's
done
i'm mad to go to bed mad
[Music]
oh god is he going to come into their
room now oh no
oh did you see that that was a ghost
holy [ __ ] wow there was the top left of
your screen
was it what did you see
did you see that pause the footage again
and we'll go look at look at the chairs
stacked up on each other what is that
oh more ghosts fly around a room oh my
god
there must be a strong paranormal
activity in this house oh
put his mask back home
there's been one thing that's really
bothering me about this guy's room he
goes back to his room again she pause it
what is that underneath his bed leg
right there like it's the level of the
bed now
is that what it is okay i thought it was
like like the air conditioning vent on
the floor or something no
it might be you're right follow the
floor here
[ __ ]
put your mask on clean your room
clean your room child i like how they
literally just went to this barren house
like he has nothing to do in there of
course he's going to go crazy well
she's got a different bed frame now what
yeah when did that change oh yeah what
the [ __ ]
and it's completely they clearly moved
the bed to set up this shot as well and
not like it matters but like
they wouldn't put a bed next to a window
sticking out
freaking psychos yeah
oh well we get the wobble going on
yeah sit back down
what's going to happen everybody's just
sleeping
[Music]
oh he did this thing again he say this
again
whoa five nights at freddy's out here
i just gotcha i'm scared bro damn bro
this is actually
i'm so started hey dude this is actually
scary
oh my god i don't know if you should
keep watching this video ken
we can't can't look away it's 10 am
we might get cursed as well if we keep
watching video we should really stop
dude we should but no we have to keep
watching what's going to happen because
we have to get to the bottom of this
nobody i'm so scared bro i can't keep
watching
no you have we got to do it just think
about how they feel bro
okay fine but if anything scary happens
i'm stopping this video now
okay oh did you see that ken he just
bashed his head in the door
oh that's kind of weird the effects
there were pretty crazy you know
because like i tried the door handle
because i think the door opens from the
outside anyway
but yeah we should probably call the
cops or something ken
no no okay they won't they they probably
wouldn't understand him bro
we need to go have a word with him we
need to go talk to him which we never
are they are they going to come and help
her
bro
were they next to him in the bed
[Laughter]
dude something's breaking what
something's breaking bro
that's the sound of something breaking
you're right
bro this is crazy
bro man dude
how big is this house
yeah they should be there by now
yeah how big are they how far away are
they
this house is huge you should be right
across in the other room they're not
going to make any time he's too far
let's go oh she's dead how did you make
it in
he just dragged her off he's like [ __ ]
i'm too tired for this
this is me i'm
oh okay is this your shirt
where'd she go oh my god she's out there
naked somewhere gotta get out of here
dude
dude did that guy take her dude i don't
know anymore
we gotta go now we gotta find her grub
we don't we gotta worry about ourselves
dude you saw me
dude screw her
a man that's what i'm talking about
that'd be me right there screw this i'm
gone
oh so you're uh you're the guy not me i
guess all right
i'll be i'll be there i'll be the other
dude they drove home and contacted on
facebook
okay that that should do it that should
do it
yeah yeah that that's the trick
that should do the trick facebook
oh they got the plaques in the wall hell
yeah
that was great i mean i gotta smash like
on that that was beautiful yeah
heck yeah nice plot twist the sun's
actually a professional basketball
player
[Laughter]
yeah i'm going to the big leagues mom
we're going together
such a really wholesome story 180
degrees parker
he's grieving man
oh man oh that's good watching dream
stands in action
this is what happens when you take away
their youtube [ __ ]
oh man that was great love that
beautiful i feel kind of scared right
now i don't know
dude that we should stop this video now
it's too scary
but there's like there's like you know
two more minutes left in the whole video
you know you got to get that
that watch time oh no oh real horror
not doing that i guess
now i gotta sleep on my back just in
case someone injects
uh sucks out spinal fluids you had it
right true i was wrong
today your birthday happy birthday i'm
sorry oh i was gonna say i usually
hammer right you know it's fine whatever
no you're not you can't take criticism
you side sleeper
oh yeah i don't know oh
no yeah
it's okay maybe you sleep like a log
idiot
no no one does that that's right i have
kids i don't sleep what are you talking
about
oh that's true that's great it was
sucking out your spinal flu
jokes in the uk
[Applause]
i'll leave it 100 000 likes and we'll do
another one oh yes
guys if video gets hundred thousand
likes remember
another collab it can check out ken bye
you thought it was gay but true
relevance
never really died welcome to the first
undead game use any item in your
inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there
stickers are emotions memes our emotions
express still emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this